with a colleague named Lara Freder we
had a big pile of spam and wanted to
know something useful to do with it and
I was curious at that time much of the
spam was touting stocks go run out by
this stock now here's your free
newsletter it's hard to imagine anybody
would go out and buy stock on the basis
of a piece of spam they got and I was
curious then why are they still sending
it so we actually ran a study to see
with the cooperation of pink sheets
which tracks many of these penny stocks
in volume and price over the course of a
day whether we saw a correlation between
the sending of these emails we ended up
accruing a pretty big database of them
and the movement of the stock price what
we basically found was yes there is a
correlation and that if you buy the
stock around the time that the email is
sent bad news it's already too late the
price is going to go down after you get
it but if you had the foresight to buy
it beforehand ie you were the spammer
probably pretty good idea enough people
will get it either because they believe
the stock newsletter that this is a
goodbye or because they believe enough
other idiots will believe it that they
just want to ride the wave then you do
well now I anecdotally seem less stock
spam lately so perhaps those
orchestrating it have moved on to a
different business but it does show that
something like spam actually can have an
effect there's still people out there
reading it and perhaps acting